okay recording started
and yeah uh welcome again to another
computer vision study group session
um I don't know if any of you has been
here before
uh yeah so in general I talk about
papers
um so it's an open study group by the
way right so if you have papers we had
some people in a channel that say like
oh yeah I would like to present the
paper so feel free to just reach out and
then we
uh yeah schedule
some date
um and talk about it
uh yeah so the way I do it mostly is
first presentation style but yeah if you
have questions somewhere in between
really just whenever just yeah
say something write in a chat
um and we'll talk so today the the topic
is the flexible paper right it's called
flexibility one model for all patch
sizes
um it's still quite a recent one right
it was released in December I think 5th
of December last year
so not even two months old
and it comes out of Google research
um yeah so basically people that also
created the the original with paper
and
um as is usual to my presentations I
give them a seam and today's theme is
wait a second oh an medieval one
so
um and the first thing I always do is a
little intro that has
a loose connection to the paper I would
say
um and is fitting the theme so for this
one I prepared the tale of Sir flexibit
right to get you in the mood like the
medieval thing
um
yeah and I just start with it
so this is a tale of Sir flexibility who
struck all monsters as he saw fit our
Story begins in an old castle deep in
the length where the stones like asleep
the old strongholds stood Mighty and
Tall loud and clear rang the angry
King's call
I'm losing my treasure I'm losing my
land all of you food sit waiting for
gold in your hand he wrote angry at the
nights in the round in all of his
kingdom none better were found all
different and still all the same all
masters of their professional game
monsters to slay was their daily meteor
and all sizes and colors they came every
day monsters so brutish and big as their
dump other small Kenny not stupid not
plump the knights they match them so
very alike some slower and rough some
quicker to strike no big night could
strike a small cheap Kiki imp nor small
Knight who stood the dragon's big Wing
thus the king had hired a horde of the
best each singer had passed their
personal test but now he laments as the
knights are so many and costs they keep
Rising he counts every penny
the same day a stranger knocked at the
gates ready to lift the king's grimmest
fate no sword no armor no gold in his
hand he looked like a peasant from the
innermost land
had me a weapon and a night worthy horse
so I can slay monsters from house to the
north
the king devastated and in great despair
gave him a blunt sword and his Greggy
old mirror months they had passed they
all thought him that when over the wall
came a dead Dragon set and in patrols
eye a Serpent's long tail nobody thought
that the man would prevail
yet there is toot all covered in blood
dirt in his hair and shoes full of mud
isolate them all for you in different
size I care not their species now I want
my price
the King was delighted invited him in
announced him a night for his special
kin
from this day on he was known as Sir
flexibility who struck monsters all
sizes as he saw fit all the other nights
they were let go the King cast them out
without Much Ado
so if you face a monster tall is a
mountain or small as grass Fear Thy not
force their flexibility will save you at
last
okay this was mostly me having fun and
you might wonder okay what has all this
to do with like a scientific paper about
machine learning right
um yeah so let's say surflexible to Who
slays monsters of all sizes
that is in a way connected
um yeah and by the way the image is
right there all created with stable
diffusion so I spend a lot of time uh
finding the right yeah
settings and Android prompts to create
nice pictures
um with stable diffusion so I don't have
to credit any any people here
um
yeah and that was the intro no we get to
read paper right and maybe a bit more
scientific so then that's the paper you
see it here like the first page of the
paper
um
so what I found interesting about their
design choice in in on front pages that
they actually took put two figures right
here and then their abstract is down
here right so
um it's already quite Visual and I mean
they put cute koalas on the front page
which is not wrong in any way I guess so
they probably get some some cuteness
scores with the koalas from the
reviewers like oh they have koalas
that's really nice
um
but yeah apart from that uh
it's not much special about the design
of the paper oh it's a two columns die
you can say right because sometimes if
one column two column
um
but that's not that interesting right
what's more interesting of course is the
content
um but first let's have a look at the
division Transformer like a little recap
on the original Vision Transformer
um what is it as I said a lot of authors
from this paper were involved in the
this original Vision Transformer thing
and it was released in 2021
and yeah it was one of the first Vision
Transformers that really could hold a
candle to a convolutionary networks in
some tasks like classification
and ever since then it's been the base
of a lot more uh yeah Transformers that
deal with vision
um the backbone of many
uh and I just want to do a little recap
on how does it actually work and what's
the problem with it why do we need
flexible
right so let's start really from the
input so let's imagine we have an input
thematically it's a dragon right
um but because it's not that good for
visualization I pixelized it quite a bit
so now basically we have
an image that is just pixels like eight
by eight pixels right in total 64 pixels
um and what we do now for with is oh
yeah he's like the pixel grid
um what we do for bit now is we say okay
we split those eight by eight pixels up
and we can actually choose how we split
them up so it should be in squares in
this case
but yeah we can do this like
four by two by two patches right so it's
four patches in total
so up here uh in every patch we have
four by four pixels
okay and that's where we have to talk
about some uh yeah some terms
because it can get quite confusing when
we're talking about the patch size we're
actually talking about
how many pixels are in one patch in one
row
or column right so we say the patch size
here would be four okay because here
it's like four four by four patch size
is four
when we talk of the grid size again we
talk of the token grid basically when
you say the grid size is two then we
mean two by two a criticize two by two
and when we speak of the sequence
that's the number of tokens in the whole
image right so the sequence length would
be four because we have four tokens here
okay so we have patch size pixels and we
have crit size which is the number of
tokens basically and then we have the
sequence lengths this is which is the
total number of tokens in this thing
okay
yeah I'm just saying this up front
because I get confused by it myself
sometimes when they they're using these
terms in the paper sometimes you're like
hey what
what is it now and yeah
so now we're all on the same page I hope
and you can start so what you do in the
vision Transformer the original one is
you take these tokens these patches and
feed them into a linear projection layer
which then gives you
for embedded
tokens basically and embedded patches
that's what you say say you can say
they're tokens and they're just these
embedded patches right so usually it's
like convolutional
layer here and that's just embedding you
some
yeah some patches and then you get in
this case you get four
tokens out of it
and you add one class token to the front
and then you give all of them their
positioner embeddings right so you add
the position embeddings to them
um sort of zero one two three four in
this case and then you take the tokens
and their embeddings and feed them to a
Transformer encoder
which is yeah just a standard
Transformer encoder basically
uh and this one then gets an multi-layer
perception head for example from which
you can then classify
whatever so in a classification case
right then you can say like okay you
know we can classify our imagenet data
set or whatever you have trained it on
um
for today for the flexibility we don't
care about most of the part that is in
the end we care about this part I would
say right a lot of the petrification and
a bit about this embeddings
stuff
okay
so next slide
let's talk about the patch size right I
already said like okay patch size
that's the number of pixels here
and we say when there are more patches
so when the patch size is actually small
right because when a patch size is small
we have more patches
and we can get an higher accuracy on
many tasks that what experiment showed
right so now we have a
smaller patch size more patches and this
gives you especially on gasification it
should like higher accuracy
I suppose it's because you can cover
more details by it right because when
you have patches like this I mean yeah
they all get lumped together in a way
or other pixels here and then you
calculate the self-attention between
these big patches
when you have smaller patches you just
have more information
I guess
um but it also comes as a trade-off that
you need more compute because now you
have to compute more self-attention
right because before I mean there's just
four tokens to compute the
self-attention between them and now you
have like 16 tokens
to compute the self-attention
yeah it actually escapes with uh yeah s
to the power of 2 with s being the
sequence lengths so the total number of
patches
yeah so that's how this surf attention
scales
but what you can do is you can actually
vary it right so when you say okay for
pre-training
um I want to use the patch size eight
so you have like the bigger bigger
patches
patch size eight right
um because it's just easier to to
compute we don't need that much
resources for pre-training and then we
actually fine tune on the smaller one
that works right you can do that
um it's not as good as completely doing
the pre-training and fine-tuning with
four for example
but it works
so exercise so the problem is that you
when you try to
change this patch size
during inference then you can actually
see quite a big decrease in performance
so this figure is a bit of a spoiler
because it shows that the flexible thing
is performing quite well what we see
here is the imagenet Precision
score on this axis
right and down here is the entrance time
sequence length that's actually I think
they got confused here a bit as well
when you say sequence length and Patch
size because I mean the sequence length
is not equal to the patch size as we
just discussed right
um so I think they mean the patch size
actually down here
so here the patches are a bigger
right 48 and that's the patch size you
have big patches and when eight is the
patch size you have small patches so
here's a higher accuracy as you can see
right
accuracy increases when the patch size
gets smaller
so actually the sequence length
increases until it's decreased but yeah
let's not get lost in that and what you
can see here is a a original model
trained on a patch size of 16 right this
bigger the lines here
and that actually also Peaks an accuracy
at patch size 16.
and when you change the patch size then
it decreases
right so it's not that good to really
yeah change the patch size at the
endurance time and the same for this
which is trained at a
patch size of 30 that also decreases
similar to the 116. yeah
so the flexibility doesn't
decrease it much as you see
but why we will see later right so first
we've got this problem of okay we change
the patch size and the whole performance
decreases but why is that right so now
we come to the the crazy Mast part of
the paper
um I took a bit of time to get through
it they have a bit of denotation and I I
think I will just quickly cover that
I mean if you're really interested in
the master part you can also have a look
at the code later on
because it's easier to understand this
code really
um than just to to go through it here
but I'd quickly try to explain their
motivation or their thoughts and what
they do to solve this problem
so let's assume we've got a small X here
which is the patch basically with the
shape of
P times P right p is the patch size only
the patch of 4x4 pixels then we've got W
which this one just looks like an upside
down M but it's a w
um and this is a patch embedding weight
which are also the same size right P by
P
and then we've got this one here which
is the dot product of the patch and the
patch embedding weights okay that's this
term
and then we've got an operation which is
called resize
to
star p y right and that means we just
resize y to Star P for example Windows
2p means we resize
y to double the pitch size that it was
before okay now to the problem right so
we've got our DOT product of the patch
and the patch embedding weights here
and then when we compare it to a resize
version of this dot product right so we
resize our patch to double the patch
size
and we also resize the patch embeddings
with it to match it right
um then we can see actually that the dot
product or they say like the magnitude
of this dot product
is only a quarter of the original all
right so it's quite a drastic change in
in this magnitude
and they are saying
they assume that might be a reason why
this performance decreases but they also
don't say like ah yeah that's that must
be the reason they say like probably
that is the reason and we are trying to
make it better so that was their
motivation it's a bit like yeah maybe it
is and uh we just do something to make
it better and in the end well
it got better so probably they were a
bit right about it
but yeah their formulation about it is
is a bit dark
so they ask themselves right are there
better ways to resize this whole thing
so this magnitude doesn't change as much
and then we get to the next crazy Mass
part where we have another track doing
Mass over here
um now we have W hat which is the new
patch embedding weights and we have B
which is a resize Matrix right and now
they say okay we want to optimize
um
this thing here
uh yeah so that actually yeah the
magnitude is not changed that much right
so what you see here is the dot product
again of the original and then you see
the dot product of the scaled version
basically then they oh get the
difference and of course they want the
difference of these two dot products to
be as small as possible
and um they say in the end the solution
is the the pseudo inverse which is
denoted by this one so the pseudonym
voice of this resize Matrix right
the whole derivation everything if
you're interested in it you can have a
look at the paper
they give the whole derivation in the
appendix
so in the end they just say okay we've
got our pseudo inverse resize and we've
shown that it's better than just plain
by linear resizing it okay
so that's their solution to the the
resizing problem
and it also shows
for example here right they've got a
comparison okay we've got a pseudo
inverse resizing and down here they've
got
um like input image size and the patch
embedding size
and it shows that when the images get
bigger
and the patches
get bigger or smaller
um then you can see actually that the
performance uh is quite good on the
pseudo
pseudo inverse resize
and for example for the vanilla resize
it's oh it's actually better when it's
it's on smaller images but when you're
on bigger images the vanilla resize is
just somewhere down here yeah
so what they used here was um it would
be
at uh yeah at eight
uh
patch size yeah
so that's where it was trained
originally at this patch size here
and then they just yeah try to resize it
in different directions and yeah you can
see especially for getting bigger the
pseudo inversary size is pretty good for
getting smaller
oh it's up to a point it's still better
than the other versions of the resizing
but yeah
it's also not perfect right
any way they use it
but of course I do more right I mean
it's not the whole contribution to just
come up with some new resizing method
and then there's the flexibility
because we've seen this picture right
and it's not just resizing I mean
resizing is part of it you can see it
here it's got your picture embeddings
and you resize so let's send the pseudo
inverse resize
you do
and uh yeah so they also have shared
rates between these flexibility on
different
tokens
different patch sizes sorry so how do
they do that actually right
[Music]
and they've got one more thing that is
helping them to yeah not having to
retrain the bit actually for different
patch sizes and still being at the
really great accuracy and it is actually
quite a simple thing when you think
about it because
um so at
training time they just say okay you
know at patch one we just take this
patch size at uh patch two
we take this patch size the next batch I
don't know we've taken other patch size
again uh batch four uh let's just uh
yeah use this patch size again so
they're randomizing the patch sizes
they're using for each batch doing
training actually
they're just yeah throwing in whatever
patch size
um the algorithm comes up with and they
also give a serial code for that you can
see here it's really just some numpy
random Choice then you give it an area
of possible patch sizes and yeah for
each batch it just chooses a patch size
and then yeah you have your random patch
size training basically
and that is quite effective so it's it's
interesting to see that like this simple
idea is that effective uh on flexifying
the bit basically
um so there's a bit more down here so
yeah I mean you can see like what
happens during the batch basically right
and
then use the the class itself the bit
and there are not many changes actually
to the original but
um but one thing they do is that they
say okay we Define like this fixed shape
of our weight which is 30 by 32 by 32
that's for the patch embedding weights
so that's like the starting point always
right and then they resize it according
to the patch size
and um for positioner encodings it's
similar they also Define like this shape
for positional embeddings
which they say seven by seven
and then they resize it
the little difference here is that they
do resize the weights with their
pseudo-inversary size but for the
positional embeddings they say like ah
it doesn't matter oh sorry it doesn't
matter which resize you use you can just
use the standard bilinear resizing
that's good enough for the position
embeddings right
and also for these numbers here 32 by 32
and 7x7 and finally they say like
actually in our experiments it didn't
really matter so they dried a range of
values and it didn't really matter which
one they choose they just then chose
like these ones because they liked it or
whatever but performance wise it doesn't
really matter if it's 32 by 32 or 12 by
12 or what else we'll say I think 24 by
24 48 by 48
you can basically choose anything
so to flexify like your standard width
when you have like this model all you
have to do really is implement this
stuff here right
so I can quickly maybe show you in the
one so
so there's this one uh pull request in
the official big vision
uh repository on GitHub it's called open
sourcing of flexibility right and then
you can find some files about it
and um well the most interesting one is
uh down here is this flick in project
models project flexi with
pi and then you can basically see
um what they modify
uh in the width to make it flexible
so here's the whole like class of the
model
right and that's that's the code they
use for it
um yeah yes also the the pseudo inverse
resize is called resample batch
embeddings
so that's the whole pseudo inverse
resize if you're interested in how that
works
that's the method for it
and yeah here's the petrification thing
and you can see here it is fixed sizes
of the position embeddings and the patch
embeddings actually the 32 with the room
and seven by seven
right so if you're more interested in
the implementation you can go through
this pull request I also put it in the
slides
so you can have a look
edit okay
but there's one more thing they're doing
and that is a oh a more common thing is
knowledge distillation right
um just a quick thing about knowledge
distillation I'm not an expert on it I
think I've actually never used it really
um I read up on it a bit
and so for example we've got an image
and we say okay we want to classify it
then we have two models actually one
which is a bit bigger we say it's a bit
B6 here and then we've got our model
which is a bit smaller which is a
flexible to be and naturally the
performance of this modem all of this a
bit worse than of the bigger model right
so now we want to
um improve the smaller model
by comparing you could say comparing the
output with the one from the bigger
model right so we say okay we've got
this image now you both get the image
and you can classify it
okay so it would be 6X okay that's a
horse the flexi that says oh I think
it's a knight oh actually it's a horse
as we see right so this prediction was
better
um and in the in the end you take both
outputs and distill them right just
sitting in this case means they are
um they have this distillation function
in this case it's a callback Library
Divergence
um yeah that they explore another paper
uh they say like oh yeah this one is
working pretty well and also uh what is
important for our knowledge distillation
is that the picture we show to both
models is really the same
um yeah because there's this method
where you just um already
like
give all the the pictures to the teacher
model and then you just save all the
outputs so it's kind of an offline
knowledge distillation but they say like
you know it is quite important to really
do it online and to really give the same
pictures to these two models and they
also use like heavy
um
what's it called augmentation heavy
augmentation on their input images and
yeah and what they also say is that it
is important to train them for quite a
long time so I mean not only the student
models really trained in this case right
so the student models uh yeah
adapted to match the the teacher model
and
over here they also saw a show
that
yeah so they first did it for like 90
epos that's this green line here and
then they did it for
I think well what was it 100 and a few
hundred more epochs and it keeps
increasing right so it these ones here
are the the longer ipoharans
um it still got better
and yeah
this is fun match Paradigm right it's
patient and consistent and what is quite
nice about this whole thing is that when
you initialize the student model in in
this case you can actually use
the parameters or the weights from the
bigger
teacher model because they are so
similar
and even though the patch embeddings or
the patch size was different here it
doesn't matter for all Flex even right
because it was trained uh flexible so it
can be initialized with these
right and this is quite beneficial some
papers have shown
um yeah it just helps in training it
quicker
and yeah we can do that here so
knowledge distillation
is that okay another part of the paper
is where they look at internal
representations that's actually a part I
really like so
they say okay we looked at different
blocks
of our models right
and
then we visualize it with this centered
kernel alignment mini batch centered
kernel alignment where you can basically
see okay we have different grid sizes
the size of each dot refers to like the
grid size
and you can see that the crit sizes of
the same block
are quite close together here so that
the representations in the different
blocks are quite similar actually even
among crit sizes it diverges a bit when
it comes to this one which is about
block six MLP right so it goes all
somewhere else like these crit sizes
hang around here and these screw sizes
around here but interestingly it does
get together again in the end so in the
last layers it again
like yeah
because closer together after diverging
in between
so yeah it shows that across crit sizes
the representations
um in the last layers are very very
close together
and they also had this cosine similarity
between Class tokens here that did it
and that shows that class tokens in old
blocks are actually quite close together
across crit sizes
yeah
Okay so
that is like some flexible stuff but now
you might wonder okay but can we also
like use it or how good is it in usage
when you use it for like classification
panoptic stuff in the true text
retrieval image segmentation right or
here is
um object detection
so what they're doing here is they take
two bits with fixed patch sizes so you
see like the B30 and the B16 and then
they take a flexi with b and they fine
tune it on these tasks with fixed patch
sizes actually as well so when they do
the fine tuning of the flexibility
here they say okay we also fix the patch
size to 30 and here to 16 right and then
they fine tune it and they show that
yeah it does actually match in most
cases the performance of like this
static width in some cases it's a bit
worse but mostly it matches sometimes
even better like here in the panoptic
case right but in general so you can use
it
to fine-tune on a fixed patch size
that's good
um
but what is also great that when you
have fine-tuned it so here you can see
like this is a fine-tuned flexibility
and green on this input crit size of 8x8
right so you have eight Patches by eight
pages
and then you want to scale it up
with the bit B30 that wouldn't work
really well so it would just like
rapidly decrease in performance and
accuracy in this case but for the
flexibility you can actually also change
the input grid even though it was
fine-tuned on this eight by eight it
doesn't really matter right so you can
still use it for other patch sizes
that's quite nice yeah over here is it's
similar right
okay
so that is when you have to like yeah
when you find room with fixed patch
sizes but they also experimented
um with flexible fine tuning right so
even when you have like your pre-trained
with B30 they thought about okay what if
we then fine tune it
um with flexible patches right so they
they applied this whole training
procedure we have the random patch sizes
and everything
um and this might be the even more
interesting case
so they're saying okay let's take it
would be 30
um you can see like the the standard
performance here so that's when in the
B30 is just
like this yeah
normally trained or fine-tuned and you
get accuracy somewhere around 79
something
right and now they say okay now we have
our flexified with B30 so they take this
is pre-draining and then fine-tuning uh
with a flexible method and it actually
shows that it's working quite well
as well so when you can then go to a 16
as patch size you get a better accuracy
um it decreases again when it's at eight
but okay so it does work actually to
flexify a formally static width so you
can do that and then
um it will most likely be a better
performance when you resize your your
patches right
uh yeah and that's similar with the
other ones here actually so again that's
image to text retrieval
um that's the object detection
and yeah
okay then they have some more ablations
which are also interesting
because I talked about this Pi resize
and they are not not really really sure
that this is really helping them
um but it's it seems like that in this
one figure that I showed before right
but there's another figure in the
appendix that made me a bit like huh but
does it really make sense because yeah
that's their figure they put in the
appendix so they didn't really hide it
or anything and you see different
resizing operations here
and um yeah we see again image net
precision
and the patch sizes down here
so we see when there's big patch sizes
so that's like big patches right
then
um yeah everything is quite low
and it's all quite
close together I would say even so when
you see the pi resize here
it is a bit on top of the others when
you have these big
patches right small criticized big
patches so Pi is a bit on top but then
well even this vanilla and vanilla they
mean like bilinia resizing is still
quite good with the flexibility here
so it's a bit like ah okay so why did
you really uh
introduce the pi resize so they're
saying like yeah it does have some other
advantages which we show in the text and
there are some but I feel like okay if
you don't want to go through the trouble
of implementing this Pi resize or
copying their Pi resize
um then you could just as well go with
the bilinear resizing really
um yeah that's at least my feeling after
seeing those figures and being like yeah
okay
the pi resizing was a nice mathematical
um experiment from their side and they
can use it but I don't think that it
will be adopted in a lot of other
architectures but maybe I'm wrong maybe
I'm just missing some vital points here
um but that is my feeling
so yeah
and there's another ablation
oh yeah this is about these fixed shape
sizes right of this positional
embeddings and the patch embeddings
um yeah so here you can see again uh
where we have the patch embeddings at
different fixed sizes like this 30 by 32
which they choose in the end but also 48
by 48 and 12 by 12 and then they again
compare it and they are quite close
together and I mean here they're really
saying like Okay it doesn't really
matter right a new implementation you
can also choose 48 by 48 and it will
still be quite good right and same year
for the positional embeddings you can
also choose like your fixed positional
embedding size of
14 by 14 and it will still be quite good
and yeah
that's uh
basically it I think yeah
that's the end
okay thank you for being here I hope you
got an idea of what flexibility is about
so in my opinion it's mostly about
randomizing your patch sizes at training
time
um
and then yeah
resizing
these fixed
embeddings that you said before
so it's actually quite an easy idea and
as I've shown you in the code right it's
not that much of Kodak it seems a bit
more here but just because of the pi
resize it takes quite a bit of space
but the changes in the model itself are
really like minimal I would say and
that's so great about the paper that you
can actually adopt a lot of
backbones and you can even yeah just as
I've shown just fine tune your
pre-trained that's
um this is flexible
training approach and then yeah it's
more flexible to different patch sizes
so it's quite a nice thing that they
showed here and yeah it's one of these
rather simple ideas
that works really well
um well in the paper they they made a
lot of other experiments right so they
when they did this and that and this
they show a lot of stuff and yeah so out
of the simple idea they made quite a big
paper and and even bigger appendix I
would say so they get in their numbering
they get all the way down to the letter
Q in in the appendix
um yeah but it's quite interesting what
they put in there as well so yeah
that is it thank you
here's some credits and the the link to
the pr actually
right
so maybe this slides if you wonder the
theme of the slides is actually like
it's called the feast of Saint Louis and
it's from the slides Go website
um yeah
and that is it for today
do you have questions
hi can you hear me yeah I can hear you
so uh I kind of missed the part how they
basically
um
taken the very variable uh tokens and
variable sequence sizes of patches right
so the the first of all they create uh
took the embeddings from the batches so
if there are variable number of patches
how do they pass it through the VIP
encoder I mean is there a linear layer
that dynamically changes its weights so
that the vit encoder can share the way
so you mean um
like if they're uh if the patch emitting
is very safe you can have a variable
sizes right yeah let's say then how does
it pass to The Vig inputer because VIP
encoder takes and I'm getting a fixed
size
and what does flexible do in this case
okay maybe we can have a look here in
the code actually maybe that's
um so what they do I mean HBC encoder
part don't use the encoder right
and they take its input
um
oh
DX okay let's let's do the backward
right
so X is
concatenated here with the class token
yeah okay it's not that important right
um
here they put the position embedding
through it okay so the position
embedding is probably already need the
right size
um
I mean uh
I'm trying to figure out
where exactly
important stuff happens do you mind if I
offer an explanation yeah sure you can
do this
um so with
Transformers in general uh to my
understanding how they work is you can
just feed them a um input sequence a
variable length
um and then this input sequence will
also have like a particular
dimensionality I believe so in NLP
you'll like have an embedding space with
different
um words being associated with different
um
embeddings
whereas with um Vision Transformers
you'll have like these patches and then
uh how it's implemented is you have this
like patchify layer with the um and it
has a convolutional layer that takes it
in um
the image and then it has a stride of
the patch size basically
and then
what this is doing is it's resizing the
weight Matrix of the
um convolutions I believe
but the convolutions will always output
the same dimensionality and um the
dimensionality of this output remains
constant for the entire model so that
doesn't have to change
um and then what the
patch uh resizing will do is if I like
have a model that has
um
like 16 by 16 patches
that will have a fixed
input sequence length however if I
change the um patch size it will have a
new input sequence length but the
Transformer is able to deal with that
um different input sequence like without
issues
yeah so that so the change happens in
the con layer that creates the patches
yeah
um the remainder of the Transformer is
fine and it'll just handle the output um
as is
okay
cool thank you
okay any more questions remarks
no not for now
oh then okay yeah I mean for me
personally with this paper I think the
most interesting part is in appendix K
actually
um where it talks about the shape and
texture bias of um flexivet and just I
guess visual Transformers in general
um I'm not sure if you're familiar with
the paper that it's citing but it's
talking about how there was a study in I
think 2018 where a couple researchers
were toying around with um I believe
resnet 50. and investigating how it's
like texture biased versus
um humans which are shape biased so like
if you pass in a textured patch of like
tiger fur it will say it's a tiger
whereas a human will be confused
uh and then if you
um I think textured the outline of a cat
with tiger fur the
um confident will say it's a tiger
whereas a human will say it's a cat
um
so that's kind of the texture versus
shape bias and this paper I believe is
one of the first to actually look into
Vision Transformers with this but um
they do end up at the conclusion that
Vision Transformers are uh shape biased
compared to
um texture bias and continents which I
think is interesting
um and I guess probably just because it
has to do with my own work but
I think that's one of the more
um
notable parts of this paper as well yeah
that's yeah that's interesting it also
reminds me of the um how do Vision
Transformers work paper I don't know if
you've read this because they they also
explored this topic a bit and they also
came to the conclusion that Vision
Transformers are more shape biased than
convolutional networks yeah
actually
their paintings is quite long so you can
really I think discover a lot of stuff
in there so it feels like they did a lot
of research a lot of experiments
actually
um and they wanted to put it all in the
paper but then again they didn't want to
be the main part too long and something
you just did a big big appendix
um but yeah they have interesting ideas
you know
um I think another issue with this paper
though is it's
even though they say that the
implementation is only three lines
um I think in reality with how at least
for um Pi torch image models that
Library the way some of the stuff is
structured makes it actually difficult
to implement the dynamic resizing um I
recall the maintainers like having
issues with that
so I'm kind of curious
as to how practical this is
um
just as
um in use
because another thing because in the
paper when they're calling the um
forward call of the vision Transformer
in addition to passing in the um
image size they also try to pass in like
a
weight or not wait um
patch size
or something
let me see
where was it
baby oh there was
here oh yeah
so I think
there's potential that that will um
interfere with some
um Downstream implementation of this
actual strategy
okay yeah interesting thought I haven't
thought about it actually
um might be uh
yeah I'm also curious how much
um
this will actually be adapted this uh
especially also for for new Transformers
maybe like for new uh bit based uh
things
right so how important is this
flexibility in the end to people
uh yeah
I guess you will see the next month
so yeah
okay well then
thank you I will stop the recording